i
[Música]
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr se le
es quien visitó mucho el mandatario
sostiene que allí ocurrió un genocidio
por los cientos de cadáveres que
encontraron tras la retirada rusa moscú
insiste en que todo es una fabricación
de ucrania
y dos gobernantes cercanos al presidente
ruso vladimir putin fueron reelegidos
para gobernar en hungría y en serbia en
los comicios del domingo el primer
ministro húngaro viktor orbán y el
mandatario serbio aleksandar vucic le
ganaron a sus opositores la unión
europea mira con preocupación su
permanencia en el poder
costa rica también eligió a su nuevo
presidente desde el 8 de mayo asumirá el
exministro de hacienda rodrigo chávez
quien en segunda vuelta le ganó por
menos de 10 puntos porcentuales al ex
mandatario josé maría figueres tendremos
reporte desde san jose
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos y comenzamos esta emisión
en ucrania el presidente de ese país
volodymyr selenski visitó la localidad
de butch a donde la alcaldía de este
suburbio a las afueras de kiev denuncia
que encontraron más de 300 cuerpos en
fosas comunes tras la retirada de las
tropas rusas el mandatario estaba con
traje militar y chaleco antibalas
aseguró que se ha vuelto más difícil
negociar con rusia desde que ucrania se
ha vuelto consciente del alcance de las
atrocidades que atribuyó al ejército de
moscú se le esquiva además denunció que
en lucha se cometieron crímenes de
guerra que serán reconocidos
mundialmente como un genocidio
estos son crímenes de guerra y serán
reconocidos por el mundo como genocidio
ustedes están aquí pueden ver lo que
sucedió sabemos que miles de personas
fueron asesinadas y torturadas
desgarradas y violadas y asesinatos de
niños
y varios líderes occidentales han
condenado la muerte de civiles en busca
el mandatario estadounidense joe biden
el presidente francés emmanuel mayo y el
canciller alemán olaf scholz respaldan a
zielinski en que esto es un crimen de
guerra y polonia pide a los altos
mandatarios europeos que sean más
contundentes con rusia mientras que
moscú llega a ser responsable de la
matanza y sostiene que todo es una
fabricación de los ucranianos tanto
ucrania como rusia pidieron una sesión
en el consejo de seguridad para discutir
qué ocurrió en el suburbio de esta
región de kiev luís muñoz y manuel acá
no nos cuentan más
civiles maniatados ejecutados con
disparos a quemarropa y una gran fosa
común las autoridades denunciaron que en
dicha localidad a 40 kilómetros de kiev
que estuvo control ruso hasta hace poco
fueron encontrados 300 cuerpos 50
habrían sido asesinados de forma
extrajudicial según versiones ucranianas
rusia enfrenta una nueva ola de condena
internacional y todos estamos
extremadamente conmocionado si luego es
condenado con la mayor de las fuerzas y
en segundo lugar está claro que hay
indicios claros de crímenes de guerra
era el ejército ruso el que estaba en
lucha sin embargo para algunos los
nuevos rechazos se tratan sólo de
palabras vacías y en mayor contundencia
para mi presidente macro
señor presidente macro no cuántas veces
ha negociado con vladimir putin que ha
logrado no se debe dialogar ni negociar
con criminales los criminales deben ser
combatidos
de voto de negocios
negociar
y ver se situarán
eeuu por su parte aseguró que vendrán
más sanciones y que reunirán todos los
detalles de lo sucedido para llevarle un
juicio por crímenes de guerra
ustedes recordarán que fui criticado por
llamar criminal de guerra a vladimir
putin bueno vi lo que pasó en lucha esto
lo justifica es un criminal de eso
la versión del kremlin es completamente
distinta y el trago esto
por lo que hemos visto las imágenes de
vídeo en muchos aspectos uno no puede
confiar en ellas porque es obvio
nuestros expertos del ministerio de
defensa han identificado signos de
falsificación los hechos y la cronología
de los eventos tampoco respaldan la
autenticidad de este alivio en este
vídeo para luego mañana
el ministro de asuntos exteriores ruso
serguéi lávrov entregó más detalles
sobre el supuesto montaje
el ejército ruso se retiró por completo
de esta ciudad el 30 de marzo 1 de marzo
de estos elementos que todo estaba
enorme pero después vimos conocido
rusia y ucrania pidieron revisar el caso
en el consejo de seguridad de las
naciones unidas y en medio de las
divisiones naciones unidas advirtió que
lo que ocurrió en lucha podría ser un
crimen de guerra y una grave violación a
los derechos humanos así lo advirtió hoy
lis tras el vocera de la oficina de
derechos humanos de la onu este
organismo pidió investigar los hechos
previamente la organización human rights
watch recopiló testimonios que probarían
que por lo menos cinco civiles fueron
ejecutados por los rusos en busán y
también tienen reportes de violaciones
sexuales en las ciudades de chernin hiv
kharkiv y kiev por su parte de la unión
europea está lista para enviar
investigadores y buscar pruebas de
crímenes de guerra en ucrania según dijo
hoy ursula von der leyen
la comisión europea
ahora continuemos con un breve recorrido
por otras noticias recientes de la
guerra en ucrania el comité
internacional de la cruz roja aún no ha
podido entrar a mariupol el portavoz del
organismo jason straziuso dijo que su
equipo fue detenido en el camino a la
ciudad gran ya acusó a las fuerzas rusas
de bloquear la evacuación mientras que
moscú sostiene que es por problemas
logísticos del csr este es el cuarto
intento fallido en la última semana para
evacuar civiles de esta urbe
hoy se reúnen los ministros de finanzas
de la zona euro para buscar nuevas
sanciones contra rusia una de las
discusiones es prohibir la compra de
energía de ese país sin embargo alemania
advirtió que no podrá parar la
importación de gas ruso pero el estado
alemán tomó temporalmente el control de
la filial de la compañía rusa gazprom
esto fue lo que dijo el ministro de
finanzas
es el momento no por el momento no es
posible cortar los suministros de gas
caps
necesitamos algo de tiempo por lo tanto
tenemos que diferenciar entre petróleo
carbón y gas en este momento code en
casa es mons y rusia restringir a
visados a los países que tilda de
inamistosos este lunes el presidente
ruso vladimir putin firmó un decreto en
represalia por las sanciones impuestas
por occidente la medida aplicará a
funcionarios diplomáticos delegaciones
oficiales y periodistas de las naciones
de la unión europea noruega suiza y
otros
más de 42 millones de personas han huido
de ucrania para buscar refugio en otras
naciones europeas como polonia o rumanía
la vecina moldavia es el tercer país que
más refugiados ha recibido con casi
400.000 según las cifras de acnur sin
embargo este territorio es uno de los
más pobres de europa y enfrenta
dificultades para ofrecer ayudas
humanitarias por eso pide apoyo
internacional para atender a quienes
escapan de la guerra desde chisinau
nuestra enviada especial del bonete
tiene el informe
este almacén se ha convertido en el
principal centro de ayuda humanitaria
organizado solamente por voluntarios y
gracias a donaciones privadas sin la
ayuda del gobierno donde vienen miles de
refugiados ucranianos que encuentran en
estas bolsas la única forma de tener
alimentos diarios de la misma manera que
también tienen productos higiénicos
juguetes para los niños ya esta ropa
porque primero los ucranianos ofrecieron
todo lo que tenían pero después de
semanas ya que cuando se pensó que la
guerra iba a durar menos tiempo después
de un mes están empezando a recibir
ayuda de organizaciones internacionales
y gracias a eso están pudiendo tener sus
necesidades básicas cubiertas a
diferencia de en otros países donde ya
están actuando mucho más fuertes
naciones unidas y han organizado campos
de refugiados aquí en moldavia por
ejemplo todavía falta mucho por hacer y
aunque hay ayuda internacional y aunque
el gobierno está intentando trabajar
para y mucha más ayuda todavía las
condiciones son deficientes y tiene que
ser gracias a los voluntarios ya los
propios civiles que están ayudando día a
día a los refugiados ucranianos
otra de las noticias en europa son las
elecciones en los comicios del domingo
hungría y serbia que eligieron a sus
mandatarios un factor que comparten el
primer ministro húngaro viktor orbán y
el presidente serbio aleksandar vucic es
que ambos son cercanos al kremlin de
hecho el mandatario ruso vladimir putin
los felicito tras su victoria y dijo que
esperaba fortalecer las alianzas algo
que la unión europea mira con
preocupación en medio de la guerra en
ucrania
el líder de la unión europea más cercano
al kremlin volvió a ganar las elecciones
en hungría la victoria del
ultranacionalista viktor orbán trajo
consigo la felicitación del presidente
vladimir putin
pese a una situación internacional
difícil el futuro desarrollo de los
vínculos bilaterales y de cooperación
corresponderá a los intereses de los
pueblos de rusia y hungría
orbán lidera una democracia y liberal
para muchos inspirada en algunos
elementos en rusia y aunque apoyó las
cuatro rondas de sanciones de la unión
europea contra moscú no colaboró con
armas ni permitió que los cargamentos de
material militar para ucrania de otros
socios pasaran por su territorio busca
la cta la coyuntura rural mcchrystal y
ahora hemos tenido que luchar contra las
fuerzas más grandes la izquierda en casa
la izquierda internacional los
burócratas de bruselas todas las
organizaciones del imperio solos los
medios de comunicación internacionales y
finalmente el presidente ucraniano nunca
habíamos tenido tantos oponentes antes
[Aplausos]
y
además celebró elecciones serbia el
populista alexander but chip fue
reelegido putin también lo felicito
espero que su trabajo como jefe de
estado continúe ayudando a fortalecer
las relaciones de asociación estratégica
eso por supuesto beneficiará a los
pueblos hermanos de rusia y serbia pese
a solicitar su adhesión a la unión
europea serbia mantiene lazos económicos
con rusia pero también culturales e
históricos el 83% de los serbios
consideran a moscú como un amigo rico
fuks visto trataremos de mantener
nuestras relaciones no sólo correctas
sino también amistosas con la federación
rusa de la mejor manera posible conoces
ahora los éxitos de los aliados de
vladimir putin marcan un nuevo camino
para europa donde hungría y serbia se
debatirán entre permanecer junto al
bloque europeo o acercarse más a moscú
sobre todo ahora con la guerra en
ucrania en pleno curso en américa latina
también hubo elecciones el domingo en
costa rica casi 2 millones de personas
votaron en la segunda vuelta
presidencial con cerca del 53 por ciento
de los sufragios el economista rodrigo
chávez fue elegido mientras que el ex
mandatario josé maría figueres del
tradicional partido de liberación
nacional se quedó con el 47 por ciento
desde san jose nuestra corresponsal
sinde y regidor nos ampliado a
previamente
con más de un millón de votos el
economista rodrigo chávez del partido
progreso social democrático es el
presidente electo de costa rica tras una
jornada electoral tranquila en la que
logró triplicar los votos que consiguió
en primera ronda se trató de una segunda
ronda cuya campaña se centró en
señalamientos negativos hacia ambos
candidatos lo cual impactó en la
participación ciudadana el
abstencionismo llegó al 42,6 por ciento
el más alto de la historia del país
incrementándose en dos puntos en
comparación con la primera vuelta chávez
gobernará a partir de mayo junto con una
asamblea legislativa en la que su
partido logró 10 diputados de un total
de 57 por lo que deberá consensuar con
otras bancadas como la más grande que es
la de liberación nacional cuyo candidato
fue derrotado por chávez el presidente
electo invitó a sus adversarios
políticos a trabajar juntos para sacar
adelante al país el ex ministro de
hacienda señalado por la sanción por
acoso sexual que le aplicó el banco
mundial- cuando elaboró allí como
directivo también deberá lidiar con
otros nuevos señalamientos como el
financiamiento de su campaña con
supuestas estructuras paralelas las
cuales no son permitidas por la ley
el presidente de sri lanka gotabaya
rajapaksa
reemplazó a su hermano como ministro de
finanzas y nombró cuatro nuevos jefes de
cartera tras la renuncia de su gabinete
el domingo el mandatario pidió un
gobierno de unidad mientras la oposición
protagoniza protestas contra la crisis
económica que llevó a declarar el estado
de emergencia el país endeudado dirigido
por raya paxia y sus hermanos en los
principales puestos están luchando para
pagar las importaciones de combustible y
otros bienes debido a la escasez de
divisas lo que provoca acordes de
energía de horas y falta de artículos
esenciales los anteriores ministros de
relaciones exteriores educación y
carreteras mantendrán sus cargas
el tribunal supremo de pakistán analiza
este lunes la constitucionalidad del
llamado a elecciones anticipadas tras la
disolución del parlamento esto después
de que el primer ministro en rne can
cancelará un voto de desconfianza que
presuntamente perdería y disolvería y
disolviera el parlamento el domingo en
una movida que ha dejado a la nación
ante una crisis constitucional ghana
alega una supuesta intervención de eeuu
para destituirlo y la oposición habla de
traición y asegura tener la mayoría
necesaria para sacar al premier del
cargo no está clara la posición de los
militares que han manejado los hilos del
poder en pakistán
y la líder de hong kong carril am que ha
gobernado la región durante los años de
agitación sin precedentes por las
protestas antigubernamentales y que
recibió el peso de la crisis del cob y
19 dijo que no buscará un segundo
mandato de cinco años en tanto los
medios dijeron que el secretario jefe
jon lee el segundo funcionario más
importante desde hong kong renunciaría
para unirse a la carrera para reemplazar
a lahm en mayo como el próximo líder del
territorio la dijo que se dedicará a su
familia
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]